I don't typically eat a lot of frozen
pizza because I spend everyday eating at
great pizza areas all around New York
I'm Scott and I run tours of famous
pizzerias and I also judge at Pizza
competitions around the United States
and write for a pizza publication called
pizza today magazine and I have the
Guinness world record for the largest
collection of pizza boxes but today I'm
going to try out some frozen pizza this
is a heinous sauce big time the taste of
tomato is not there at all it's
completely masked there's oregano and
garlic but it's that cheap garlic powder
taste a very monotonous bite it's kind
of a one-trick pony type of chew a lot
of pizzas have a crisp enos and then a
chewiness and this one's sort of it's
the same the whole way through it's one
color oh we got a square renegade an
interesting dual text troop when you get
past the snap there's this chewiness on
the inside I think after the excitement
wears down of that initial bite you're
left with this kind of gummy very white
bread it's a very white bread crust
they've got an excellent cheese dough
sauce ratio if I could stick this
topping onto a decent crust we might
have something here but I'm kind of into
it so I can eat this whoa feels like a
cracker oh god it's a there's like a
weird barbecue thing going on the press
is definitely drying me out so I need
moisture from the sauce I'm not getting
a lot of it cuz there's not a whole lot
of sauce I really do want to look at it
looks tastes awful oh my god it was a
square
really soft trust with this one not
crunchy no sound shoe a really chewy
gummy crust or do not enjoy it this one
is definitely more about the cheese I
can taste the cheese in this one thank
know Pizza of gods the sauce isn't no
flavor at all this is a cheese party
it's all about the cheese on this one
yeah this one's really lifeless it's
it's just like it's asleep Wow the crust
is terrible very robust sauce major
garlic action it's got this weird
chalky thing on the crust although I
don't hate it
whoa-oh-oh-oh whose cheese drag we have
cheese drag can I can I seriously use
this blindfold as a napkin because I
will major cheese drag which means we
have a lot of moisture which is great I
mean finally we have some sauce here
this is kind of a confusing pizza but I
do not dislike it this one was kind of
nice and tasted okay
I am not at all surprised because like
frozen pizza is basically like cardboard
and gluten-free pizzas like cardboard
anyway so this is great I'm glad you
guys did this thanks for doing this
Trader Joe's 3 cheese gluten-free pizza
and I liked it